hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember so you don't have to omorrow
Wilson your place is welcomed among the
child actors that just kept picking
shitty movies yeah you were cute you
could act okay
you had that play she's wittle wrists
that makes me want to grab my teeth to
shards unless I get arrested which is
very unlikely that's Christmas even I'm
going to bed uncharacteristically early
and just in the middle of being the cute
little button that American ever wanted
sewed on comes this charming little
disaster simply known as a simple wish
oh yeah this is a nightmare of adorable
proportions its clunky it's stupid it's
as awkwardly enchanting as a magic show
performed by Janet Reno it's just one
friggin mess divert to worse reasons to
rip on a child actress but I'm gonna do
it anyway this is a simple wish so you
know this movie's in trouble when you
find one of the main sponsors is the
bubble factory you ever wonder if it's
actually like a legitimate bubble
factory if so you gotta wonder how that
meeting went all right people we already
know that the build-a-bear workshop it's
a great success by Nancy Terminator 2 so
I say we go into finding some movies
let's see we have this laura wilson
fairy tale or a movie about the sinking
of the Titanic Oh Anne's a downer let's
go in tomorrow Wilson fairytale Wow who
is that guy so we start off once upon a
time three months ago you know do you
really need the phrase uh time when you
have the time where we see the fairy
godmother exams taking place while the
credits roll hey look it's the guy we
all know is funny but for some reason is
constantly not funny oh yes Martin Shore
for whatever reason always decides to
leave his talent at home whenever he
goes on scream I don't know if he needs
better direction or a better agent but
needless to say he scenes do have sort
of a no how do I put it
junus a drop there Fred to them your
bully like me Oh
I was on SCTV really cut to three months
later so present-day could have saved
six letters there where we see a horse
and buggy ride driver named Oliver off
to pick up his kids oh wait we have to
have this pointless slapstick moment we
I bet this leads to nothing and it
doesn't stupid movie looking stressed
today
just another day fears are walking JC
Penney's commercial
yes Morrow Wilson plays a girl named
Annabelle and this table scraps of the
90s is her brother named Charlie let's
just face it dad's never gonna come he
left us here arrived please that seemed
more badass 90s kids out of Kazaam oh
wait he wasn't Kazaam allow me to judge
this performance particularly harshly
and unfairly for that they're excited
because their father has an audition for
a Broadway musical which appears
unlikely seeing how he looks and sounds
like a sodomized recording of Dom
DeLuise is it good to be late your
audition yeah no no let's be too nervous
since one is 6 minutes incredibly late
huh I gotta be half the cast of a Dom
booth movie in an hour but who knows
maybe he has some talent
all right scum creepy dog or a good dub
over artist
really that's him singing huh yeah right
that's Cary Elwes and quest for Camelot
even Murray Vanilli would call bullshit
on this one
and for my next audition I'll sing
Charlotte Church and Josh Groban both at
the same time so he doesn't get the main
role because it's already been promised
to a big Broadway star which leads to
the fairy godmother retreat via no segue
at all
I do believe another years gone by why
do we have to check our mom's really I
feel like ever that well it's like in
the Old West
all the cow bones hedges check their
guns before they Mose it into town
especially in Dodge City and that's why
nobody got plugged yes it's like going
to an NRA meeting and asking everybody
to check their rifles I'm sure
everybody's gonna follow that and
nothing bad is gonna happen at all but
one fairy godmother forgets to make it
to the retreat yes which one that is you
don't look a whole lot like the one in
Cinderella oh you you mean the whole guy
thing can I have something what
difference does it really make where the
magic comes from indeed as a
middle-class white American male we have
been oppressed too long boy this is some
swell room huh well Missy look at all
the guests
step away from the unfunny writing hmm
hello there
my name is Murray Sowell you might be
wondering like he looks like Doctor Who
if he graduate from Hogwarts Murray
realizes he's late for the retreat and
leaves Annabel accidentally dropping his
magic wand behind but little does he
realize not showing up might have worked
out for an evil witch played by Kathleen
Turner shows up and is here to out lug
Martin short as much as she can yeah
oh wait mwah oh you can't be serious
do I look like a witch wait you know you
really should leave by the way yes that
is Teri Garr from Young Frankenstein has
the secretary named I'll go ah
but before I do I remembered what a
healthy appetite you have Teri Garr and
a healthy appetite
I'm gonna use my get out your free card
on this one I brought you a little
something from my garden oh my yeah it's
the reddest apple I think I've ever seen
oh it tastes even better than it looks
yes when as a woman offering an apple
ever led to any unpleasantness in past
literature what is with you I've got to
pee which you were just outside I always
lose it when I get nervous I think I
liked it better when you were a dog
personally I liked her better when she
was a honey bunny she did appeal not in
that will be too weird connection
Claudia I took your wand away because
you were using it for your own selfish
ends that is not what very godmothers
are all about we use them to help other
people selfish ends so Turner
turns her into Jackie paper just as gar
starts to pointlessly wake up now
nothing is wrong
nothing is wrong everything is perfectly
normal
Hortense is flat perfectly normal
Hortense is flat these aren't the droids
you're looking for these aren't the
droids we're looking for
she likes all the fairy godmothers
downstairs and leaves with all the wands
while that's going on we see Annabelle
and her father discuss the always
classic single parent syndrome that
seems to invest most children's fairy
tales dad remember I said mom you into
heaven house she's an angel huh hmm are
you making that a
I believe you know but I also think that
this is a big part of itself right here
we're not I mean I see her when I look
at you now in all fairness this is not
that bad a scene in fact a lot of the
moments with Annabelle and the father
actually work okay I surprisingly find
myself more interested in him getting
the part for the play in her connection
with him much more interesting than
anything else in this movie no speaking
of which hello I heard you were having a
dramatic moment I'm here to mug it away
no no let me guess he shows off his
funny faces and does something clumsy
Africa fast-forward
we see the next day that Charlie
accidentally breaks the wand by crashing
into a bunch of box
shit did you get his license number oh
wait he has a license number
okay kids stop turning my jokes into
things that exist so while drinking her
dry eyes Turner realizes that one wand
is missing the one Annabelle has of
course and in order to rule all the
blahblah yadda-yadda she has to find it
come I'm in broad daylight for years I
love this mirror right boat get change
purpose gasps of purpose please but who
was the point of that she liked a mirror
okay what does they have to do with the
story or even the character ha I love
this mirror do the rulers of darkness
just as serious a dee dee I will destroy
the Smurfs with all my magic spells
ha ha ha ha ha ha let's say did you
realize that the guy who did the candle
from Beauty and the Beast was also a
law-and-order that's so weird
haha
hahaha so while at school animal tries
to put her wand back together but the
teacher is not pleased with her lack of
focus a place can't be any worse than
this lack of focus it's something I have
to fix it's not our assignment
hand over your toy it's not a toy it's a
magic wand now give that to me don't
make her go Matilda on your ass I wish
you let me have it
oh I can't wait to see what this is
building up to okay come on that's like
a clown being a consultant at a Pie
Factory
even the obvious payoff will be funnier
than no payoff I wish you'd let me have
it
I don't see it didn't make sense but
there was something so she leaves the
classroom and comes across Marie who
despite seeing that the wand is broken
thinks he can still get it to work I
wish don't when my dad sings tonight he
gets the part toy you can dad what yes
but not here see the grantor of the wish
namely me has to be within a hundred
yards of the beneficiary which is your
father
Jesus this movie has more rules than a
Dungeons & Dragons game try and see in
your head see the Plaza Hotel
okay that doesn't happen despite how
nice that would be
but we do see them accidentally end up
at the Plaza motel in Nebraska which is
not as impressive oh you're unbelievable
can't you even admit it didn't want that
you blew it you totally screwed my wish
oh no need to did not dig - did not
it's fucking riveting as this dialogue
is why doesn't he just transport them
back why are they still there is that
ever explained
I mean we're 40 minutes into this
clunker and the most magical thing
that's happened so far is we've gone to
Nebraska if they're anything in the
scene that needs to keep us in this
location okay a possible chance for
death I'm all for that
Oh Roy hey Roy but it says on his shirt
yeah right my shirt so good I got a
brother Roy is that his shirt what Freud
dad I needed a clean shirt Wonderman
enchantment first-degree murder over a
brother's clean shirt
look out Mary Poppins you've been out
wizzy hang on to this not you boy okay
just because it worked in your one-man
show doesn't mean it's going to work
here
not everyone has a My Big Fat Greek
Wedding hot guy what you get in wave it
around turn me to some little funny red
do it Murray
turn him into a little rabbit fucking
mutt Murray fuck him up something good
shabbu
look at Salvador Dali in his most
drug-induced nightmares - and have
dreamt this up somebody actually wrote
this this isn't a fairy tale two stoners
adventure doing mad libs it's my
favorite part of Central Park
I'd ask why they didn't just do that
before but then we wouldn't missed out
on the classic 50 story rabbi see and
Lord knows we wouldn't want a nice
cinema that so they find the father and
Marie tries to finally grant the wish
but then he accidentally turns him into
a statue oh we are supposed to be
rooting for this guy right I mean
there's making mistakes and then there's
just committing these horrible crimes of
hell magic and what point do you draw
the line I wish so when my dad sings
tonight yes the part absolutely shoo
shoo shoo boom oh I accidentally started
the Hunger Games
I'm so sorry people dying everywhere but
you know I'm so quirky so they had to
wear the fairy godmothers meat so they
can figure out how to get their father
back only to find a flattened judge doom
here surprise I tried to keep my wish
simple there's no such thing as a simple
wish yeah if only that were true
this spell of Marie's it must be lifted
before midnight after that your father
will most likely remain a statue forever
you promised your what nothing I just
said that we get the belongs back yeah
another nice segue we don't know why
getting the wands back will fix
everything or why they can't just wait
for the other one to be fixed or why
they can't just find another one I mean
there has to be extras or why the hell
they can't just unlock the door and ask
one of the other fairy godmothers down
there to help in fact do we ever see
them again I don't think we do for all
we know they're just left down there
starving to death hanging on to what
little life they have good news fairy
godmothers your free day
but they first have to stop the audition
of the other singer from going well so
that their father can still possibly be
considered as a standby okay your
father's a pidgin toilet right now and
may stay like that for the rest of his
life off the audition and focus on
bringing him back to life you priority
askew mental cases oh no it rained a bit
and he can still saying that was
pointless this movie has more padding
than a goddamn hockey player so he tries
another spell to give him a frog in his
throat literally the pencil sketch is
for Prince Naveen look more
three-dimensional than those frogs don't
high but the dog lady finds the two of
them and decides to take them to turn
boots move executes every motherfucking
last one oh yeah
so she takes them to the witch where she
forces them into the most evil
disgusting horrifying torture imaginable
hurry please oh I don't wanna dance I
can't stop
somebody help by being slightly
inconvenience come on Claudia this is so
demented won't anybody stop this mild
nuisance ah we have a fabulous conductor
oh no she's conducting now the horror
help you copy hey wait a minute she
jumped up to the conductor but now she's
settling back over there also being the
confessor but she has to disappear for a
minute so why did you reappear back
there and what did I say earlier
I'll tell everything you want to know
just give me a better agent both oh
brother sneaks in and gets them the real
magic wand what follows is a climax of
whimsical effects I mean I know nothing
can outdo that jump cut from earlier but
still they're pretty impressive for a
first year CG student and Turner
accidentally zips the mirror which
somehow causes her to get sucked into it
yeah that was the connection from
earlier remember how she said I love
this mirror that apparently was code for
if I zap this thing I'll be entrapped in
it for all eternity you know what will
have been more constructive and
explanatory if she said hey if I zap
this thing I'll be entrapped in it for
all eternity
skur it's there not just for plays
anymore the one turns everything back to
normal the singer gets into an accident
which means the father gets to perform
of course he's a big kid and they all
live goddamn stupid movie ever after so
on a scale of 1 to 10 this blows the
story's not very focused the comedies
not very funny the characters are not
very relatable and even the effects are
ridiculously lame granted some of the
scenes between the father and daughter
work and to her credit mara Wilson isn't
all that bad in this but I'm sorry I'm
just not a fan of her movies I mean it's
like everything mara Wilson touch back
then just turned to crap I mean look at
her
with her couch her modern day haircut
her 25 year old body her vengeful eyes I
seem to be looking directly at me right
now - hello critic Morrow Wilson I heard
you've been saying some pretty nasty
things about me okay forget it Missy you
knew what you were doing back then as a
kid if you didn't want people like me
making fun of your work you would have
chosen so many crappy movies I don't
care how old you were
so you think kids should be held
accountable for what they film no matter
what their age damn right sister because
I came across some interesting videos
from a little town called Bothell
Washington Bothell Wash
yes of a certain internet critic who
made movies when he was a young lad
you're bluffing you don't really have
those videos roll the film
I hope you don't
ah isn't it wonderful
these birds I'll tell you what the
problem is we are Iliad just look at
those performances so restricted so
reserved truly the epitome of subtlety
shut up and just look at those glasses
only a true master of character would
wear something so hideously embarrassing
your regular Daniel day-lewis
said and how brave of you to go with
those braces tell me was it meant to
look like your teeth we're eating over
them chop the acne is a nice touch - I
bet you purposely never showered just to
get that effect
it was Seattle during the grunge era
none of us Daniel oh and you must have
been a fan of my work we have the exact
same hairstyle tomorrow lesson one
natural egg kind
oh and how did some of that dialog go no
it was brilliant writing you and they're
totally unforgettable mark please I know
I remember I like wearing women's
clothing it's fun oh my god how could
you be so heartless how could you be so
cruel
unholy she-demon well so long critic I'm
sure now that the public have seen your
brilliant choices as a child they'll be
just as accepting as you were of mine
Oh
and I ever
before
you'll want to
miss me but not to kiss me
it's
Oh
your regular Daniel day-lewis